getting a budget alert when your Google
cloud platform costs exceed your budget
is a great way to stay on top of your
cloud costs but cost controls are more
about than just avoiding billing
surprises it's also important to provide
the flexibility you need to scale and
have a way to restrict unnecessary costs
on this episode of beyond your bill
we'll talk about how programmatic budget
notifications can be added to your
budgets and give some examples for
setting up advanced cost controls
[Music]
in our previous video we went through
setting up budgets and alerts in the GCB
console which trigger email
notifications since budget alerts are
sent to billing account administrators
and billing account users you can easily
control who gets those notifications
however that means you may need to wait
for those people to talk to the right
teams an investigative changes need to
be made if you want to put more
proactive controls in place programmatic
budget notifications can allow you to
run code based on your budgets after
choosing the thresholds when setting up
a budget you can connect cloud pub/sub
to the budget we'll choose a project and
a pub subtopic to receive notifications
once the budget is publishing to pub/sub
you can have any number of subscribers
that will handle the notifications such
as cloud functions for our example if
you're not familiar with pub/sub think
of it as a simple message handler which
passes on any events such as budget
updates to any services that are
subscribed to it cloud functions is a
lightweight way and server this way to
run code and it's an ideal solution for
quickly handling budget alerts any
budgets you create with a pub sub topic
will publish the current status of a
budget multiple times per day rather
than waiting for a threshold to be
crossed with each budget you set up you
can have both email notifications and
programmatic notifications when setting
up advanced cost controls like this one
you'll want to make sure that your
finance teams and your IT teams work
together since this process involves
both sides once you've got everything
connected with pub/sub the cloud
function will receive notifications with
some important information such as the
billing account ID the display name of
the budget the most recent threshold
exceeded and the amount of your costs
for the scope of the budget now that
you're writing code with this
information you can pretty much do
anything the Google cloud platform API
will let you do one very common example
is to post an update to slack or other
platforms connecting any tools your team
uses to stay on top of your costs again
this keeps people up to date but we can
also automate direct cost controls to
respond to these notifications one of
the more drastic actions you can take is
to disable billing for a project
entirely for example you may have a
development or test environment and a
dev team that constantly spins up
resources in that environment if someone
on the team spins up an expensive
resource like a large compute in
and then forgets to turn it off it can
rack up costs pretty quickly one way to
avoid this may be to set a budget and a
programmatic budget notification that
removes the billing account from the
project after the specific cost is
reached it's important to note that when
you disable billing on a project all the
billable resources for that project are
shut down and then deleted this is
probably not something you want to do in
a production environment but it can be a
quick way to make sure that you set a
very hard limit for your costs on that
specified project sometimes a more
nuanced approach is better such as
limiting the number of resources that
can be spun up with quota or simply
stopping all the compute instances
without deleting them that way you're
not paying for them and the appropriate
team can investigate why the usage was
higher than planned there's some sample
code in the links below for sending
alerts to slack disabling billing for
our project and for stopping all compute
instances when you hit a specified
budget amount these are great starting
points and they're easy to extend with
just a little bit of code to fit your
business needs when testing your code
you can manually send pub/sub messages
so you don't actually have to wait for
the budget amount to be triggered
another driver of unnecessary or
accidental costs can be from resources
that aren't being used optimally
over provisioned resources are larger
than they need to be to serve their
current workloads and since the cloud it
can be easier to scale them down as
needed idle or part-time resources can
also be an easy target for saving costs
since they can be stopped or scaled down
when they're not at peak usage this can
also be automated on a scheduled basis
such as regularly looking for resources
that aren't being used and removing them
two great examples of this are linked
below both walk through taking advanced
actions such as removing unused IP
addresses in attached disks moving
Storage buckets to less expensive
storage classes based on their usage and
setting up a schedule to start and stop
compute engine instances using
programmatic budget notifications is
another step towards being able to set
up cost controls that match with your
business needs each business is
different so the specifics depend on the
amount you're looking to automate and
extend your cost controls but the links
below give you a great starting point
and provide some sample code check them
out and get a better handle on
controlling your cloud costs
[Music]
Oh